on est bien que deux choses et mon amie
la rose me l'a dit ce matin à new moore
je suis baptisée de rente ai
je me suis épanoui
il
bonjour et bienvenue pour le quatrième
rendez vous avec votre émission le petit
émir comme vous l'avez vu la semaine
dernière à lire sam de la ressource
les castings battent leur plein et
maureen émis florian thomas et kevin
était très motivé cette semaine nous
vous emmenons toujours en compagnie de
marie qu'à la metteuse en scène de notre
pièce à l'ime de la montagne pour un
nouveau casting très percutant
hélène musicothérapeute expérimentés
nous fait ainsi découvrir les talents de
marco david nicholas et cédric la séance
débute par une exploration des
instruments alors comment on découvre
d'abord l'instrument vous allez essayer
de trouver tous les sons que vous pouvez
produire avec votre instrument
donc ça veut pas dire juste laissons là
dessus ça peut être aussi au niveau du
support vous allez chercher tous les
sons que vous pouvez trouver après
l'exploration place au duo c'est david
le premier
ouais les duos s'enchaînent et ne se
ressemblent pas
tu joues avec moi concentre toi
après les duos hélène et marika test
l'oreille musicale de leurs élèves en
leur demandant de reproduire des sons à
l'identique
cette fois ci c'est nicolas qui débute
bien c'est très très bien
david arrêts
maintenant que tout le monde est bien
chaud c'est le moment du concert final
car n'oublions pas qu'une troupe
c'est avant tout un groupe
après ce concert explosif c'est
maintenant l'heure du bilan
en mode bonne humeur pour marika et
hélène
l'idée c'est de découvrir les potentiels
des jeunes que nous accueillons dans nos
établissements et on pense que vraiment
l'art la culture la musique sont des
médiateurs des outils qui les font se
révéler on voit des jeunes très inhibé
par exemple comme cédric ben qui après
avec la musique avec la percussion
arrive vraiment à ceux à s'exprimer à se
sentir bien donc c'est vraiment un
travail intéressant et voilà c'est ça
fait partie de notre métier de l'art
thérapie la musicothérapie pour arriver
à ce qu'ils s'expriment et qui se
sentent mieux voilà donc j'ai mis en
place différents ateliers dont cet
atelier de musicothérapie actifs
quitteront plus autour de la percussion
et où j'essaye de donner la possibilité
aux jeunes de s'exprimer par
l'intermédiaire des percussions c'est
terminé pour aujourd'hui ce quatrième
casting s'achève dans la bonne humeur en
sera-t-il de même lors de notre
cinquième épisode
la semaine prochaine nous vous
emmènerons au centre de la ressource ou
marica pourra revoir sur scène cette
fois-ci les élèves des épisodes 1 et 3
lors d'un spectacle en public ce sera
peut-être l'occasion pour elle de se
conforter dans ses opinions et vous le
verrez d'effectuer déjà les premiers
choix à très bientôt donc